I'm walking in this morning with Ronnie
right yeah and I see you in the hall and
you turn around I go hey JD how you
doing and you just start laughing
looking at Ronnie a problem yeah but I
mean but Ronnie wasn't doing anything
funny he doesn't have to do anything
funny around and I go hey good morning
JD he goes commercial this morning for a
drug for people who laugh inappropriate
a drug to lady pseudobulbar affect or
PBA is a medical condition that results
in sudden and uncontrollable episodes of
laughing crying or both do you got
pseudobulbar I know he does when you're
not talking to him in meetings I know he
sits away from everybody today he has to
sit at the table are those all symptoms
of pseudobulbar I don't know if
pseudobulbar covers them he could have a
number of syndrome hmm a person with PBA
may laugh at something that's sad or cry
at something that's funny
when's the last time you just started
crying out of the blue well no I mean it
felt like sobbing it's just like tearing
up like all right so when's the last
time like a couple minutes of like right
now right and that doesn't distress you
I mean it makes me feel weird let me
look at you you're coming right here are
you crying or you get some kind of like
dry eye or something no I it's just it's
it's teary crying I don't know what do
you feel sadness no that's why Wilde is
right what is it thinking about your
mortality no I mean are you thinking
about anything no just waiting for the
next class my god you crying morning
crying
it turned out we gave JD an online quiz
from PBA info org they say if you score
13 or higher Europe likely to have PBA
JD scored 222 Wow
I would think it was weird if I just
started laughing uncontrollably a weird
[ __ ]
but when you've done it all your life do
you think it you would notice it by now
it's a humor right laughing the easy
sense of humor I think this is something
wrong with you